so anya and mimi i have a question for
both of you first because i always love
asking about the value of a good scene
partner and i'm especially interested in
hearing how that relationship evolved
for you too given how different yen and
frangelo's material is in season two so
what is something you've come to
appreciate appreciate about the other as
a scene partner more than ever in season
two given how the characters evolve
alongside each other
i learned so much from you mimi
yes it's jennifer but me like as annie
as well i think you're an amazing um
i think you're amazing
i just do i love watching you i love
watching you in the season in those
series and just playing against you is
just
like
i don't know it's it's just someone i
just you i find you so easy to work with
i can't see you on the screen so i'm
sorry but i really do um so it's just
been a joy to have that journey with you
um as jennifer
same thing i think she learns a lot from
fringilla
um they're both kind of connected by the
experience they've shared and
connected by you know they really i
think they really love each other to
some degree and um they just have to
they have to find a way individually
through this world and as as kind of the
the women of this world it's quite it's
quite harsh sometimes um it's a very
brutal
kind of world and you kind of can't rely
on anyone so it's hard for you to
properly form the relationships that you
you may want to or
yeah i think
so it's a complex one
the feeling is so mutual like i love
working with anya um
and it's the detail like anya as an
actress is very detailed
and um
you can do a take and it can you'll
watch it as her scene partner be like oh
my god that was incredible and then
she'll be like i think i missed
something what do you think this means
or what do you think did it and then
she'll give you another take that is
just equally as incredible
and
and so you can't work with anu and not
grow and search for new things because
like her presence just doesn't allow it
and
so i love that about her and in terms of
frangela and jennifer's dynamic
fingernail learns a lot from yanova but
i think it kills her to show them that
so when they're together
you'll get this kind of you're not
affecting me and then when they're apart
you see
just yen influencing decisions and
choices
um and i i love that about their
relationship i think she kind of looks
up to her in some way i honestly do i'm
gonna put the spoiler warning up because
joey i feel like i can't ask you any
questions unless i'm potentially
spoiling something and this gets into
some details here i think this is very
well covered and clearly conveyed in the
show but when i'm moved by something i
tend to get greedy and want to know more
about it so was there any additional
backstory work that you needed to do on
your own to really determine why ask air
became the sandpiper and maybe more
specifically where he found the faith in
himself that he was capable to do that
wonderful question thank you and in my
preparation for season two i um did a
fair bit of research into
uh entertainers throughout history who
use their platform and their uh position
within a fame within the entertainment
industries to to do good um
amazing people like josephine baker um
the early years of even marcel marceau
uh
like all they all used
their position in society as performer
and and as and in some ways being out
outside of society and commenting on
society but they use their fame to um to
do some real good particularly in times
of war or turmoil and so that greatly
influenced me when i was prepping
uh and to answer the second part of your
question i think uh
you know the best artists in the world
always respond to the world around them
and um and want to
adapt and become part of that movement
and so if the world is becoming darker
becoming grittier then i think
um the artists sometimes do that or
sometimes they push against that and
throughout season two we get to explore
we get to see oscar exploring that
whether he wants to
kind of
accept that this is a horrible horrible
place to live or fight against it and
try and find the optimism and the light
in himself and in everyone around him so
that sort of dichotomy is something that
i uh really enjoys kind of walking that
tightrope walk on really
all right i'm coming your way with a
spoiler question now because you know i
would say frangilla had a fairly
one-track mind in like the future
material in season one but it's like a
real wealth of of nuance and layers for
you this time around so was there any
particular new element or side of the
character that felt
especially rewarding for you to tap into
that you're excited to share with fans
yeah i remember in season one constantly
having discussions with lauren about
um
internal struggle
and me sometimes being like oh shall i
show it here or did it and it was like
no let's just wait because it's coming
right
and so this season i love the fact you
get to see how she makes decisions you
get to see who influences her and who
she really doesn't want to be working
with but she has to in moments
and that's really fun to play i love
that dynamic and that struggle in her
great success in that department and
y'all come in really with more questions
later today but huge congratulations to
all three of you i love the new season
you